[Music]
Meredith how are you doing really
conflicted there's been a lot of stuff
going on lately whether it's career
stuff lots of frustration around that
you know being an employee where you
don't feel as Belliard being on the
front lines so it's kind of hard to deal
with and I've been in contact with my
dad who I considered dead to me three
years ago and it's been a lot so how am
i I'm okay sometimes but I could use a
good crier - yeah what caused you guys
to reconnect he went to rehab and
because he was on meth doing a lot of
drugs and his ex told us that he had
been doing that he'd been getting better
and when they last spoke he said that my
dad told him he knew he knew he could
have been a better father to us growing
up and it just
I needed to hear that yeah he doesn't
apologize but in that way that was him
apologizing what do you that you got to
hear that from them after all these
years yeah not many people get closure
but yeah thank you for listening
yeah thank you for sharing what's in
your mind right now I've been recently
unemployed so I'm a little overwhelmed
with what I'm gonna do next you know
it's funny that you should say that
because I feel the same way I still have
no idea what I want to do I'm happy that
I have a job but it's not something that
I want to do you know I still gotta find
my passion my truth there's a little I
guess comfort to know that I'm not the
only one going through it yeah I mean
I'm sad that we're all going through it
yeah makes me feel less lonely I guess
how old are you I'm 31
how old are you I'm about to be 30 I'm
29 I mean we're both still young yeah I
know hopefully we'll get there but you
know be positive and all that you know
can only once again stick you so far but
we got to do what we got to do yeah what
is the most romantic thing that's
happened to you most romantic I think I
think I can think of one I actually got
picked up from therapy super romantic
had bawled my eyes out for like an hour
and got picked up with some of my
favorite food and we went to like a park
at the beach that I hadn't ever been to
and we just ate and played catch with
this thing called in a row B I was
freezing and usually I'm I can't deal
with the cold very well but I remember
just thinking to myself how like the
cold didn't bother me so I think maybe
that
maybe that time hmm and you said
therapy's yeah do you go to therapy
I used to I'm gonna use it when I know I
need it yeah yeah my mental health stuff
started coming up since I was like 12 or
13 so been there done that okay do you
mind me asking like do you have any
diagnoses or is it just for talking to
someone
um I've struggled with depression since
I was super young like eight so I guess
that would be my official diagnosis okay
are you on antidepressants or anything
no I haven't been for a while I haven't
enjoyed the ones that I took for how to
make me feel so been trying to do it
other ways doing it naturopathic layer
with exercise and sleep and just taking
care of myself
yeah good for you what about you oh yeah
I'm gonna answer both questions out of
the list yeah I forgot what the original
question would you want to answer the
mental health wishing for um oh god
where do I start
major depressive disorder anxiety PTSD
anxiety is getting better thankfully
it's gone now my doctors are on the
track of ADHD I've got diabetes hashey
motos my health is all like all over the
place if it weren't for some of my meds
I'd be practically a puddle of mush
again I couldn't function for a long
time
so I'm glad to hear that they're working
for you thank you that's a big blessing
I'm sure yeah I felt like I lost six
years of my life now it's definitely
catching up I'm enjoying it that's good
the other question I think was whenever
you felt most romance didn't you like oh
and I'm sorry I love you that's my my
fiance's a word we've all dated okay one
that comes to mind first date I meet
this guy at a coffee shop and after that
he takes me to his plane and yes I said
his plane and he flew us from
Albuquerque to Santa Fe
Wow and from Santa Fe I was able he
taught me how to fly a plane and it's
like you know one of those like little
wines you can only see it like two
people look not every day you get to say
oh yeah
yeah he took me on a plane and taught me
I could fly it yeah what's the most
romantic thing that's happened to you
the most romantic thing it is hard
because I need shots for this idea I was
engaged eight months eight months ago so
that thing that ended you know but I met
her four years ago we were going to
Catalina Island and we took a ferry and
it was me my brother and then this girl
was sitting with her friends and I was
like a bachelorette party and she was
just sitting you know right across for
me and I caught her looking at me and I
grew up in Boston in Boston people kind
of forward so I look at her I was like
what are you looking at you know a guy's
flying away and she's like oh you have
you know nice skin I was like oh that's
creepy thank you I appreciate that
so she laughs I laugh and then after the
boat stopped we walk towards the island
and it was very like platonic
conversation you know and I got to know
her a little bit and then in the end
where I was like there was like two ways
separating so she went with her friends
and then I went with my brother and our
and my friends and you know I told her
like it was really nice meet her and
hopefully you know come
cross again and a couple of time has
passed and then I was with my brother we
got another group talking and then I saw
her and then I rode away ran up to her
start talking to her and something told
me that I had to kiss her I was like hey
I have to kiss you
she's like what get away from me you
creep you know fun way I guess right
like I'm sorry I have to kiss you
something's telling me
so I'll she's like fine so I kiss her it
was like a really good novella kiss you
know to me like that good the leg goes
up after that the whole trip was just me
and her flirting then she went back home
to Philadelphia I went back to San Diego
so she moved here we starting it out and
then one thing led to an out there and
then we started living together and then
I asked her to marry me
you know we were in Greece but the thing
is with me is I like to make people
happy regardless of what I want
strangers friends family just I don't
care just as long as you're happy so the
idea of marriage was her idea and then
that idea became kind of big in my mind
now I was like I don't know if I want to
marry her which is sucks cuz she's like
six years older than me
she's ready to settle and then she's
like this is the ring I want him like
sure absolutely and it's something just
hit like I don't know if I want to marry
her which is such which she broke my
heart because I felt like I wasted her
time and I wanted to be with her but
something happened like why this
happened you know to me like who's
laughing at this who it's not funny so I
still feel guilty you know but then I do
the whole move out and all that fun
thing cry a lot you know the huge I'm
sorry that happened I know
peachie moment what about you any fun
sad story
fun sad story I can't really think of
the last romantic thing that's happened
to me I am I'm very torn between liking
romance and not I feel like that I like
the idea of it when it's but when it's
done to me
it just doesn't feel very natural maybe
because it doesn't come from the right
person yeah
it's happened a couple of times but it
just it makes me uncomfortable because
it's not from the person I would want it
to be from oh I see do you have somebody
mind and wanted to just ask him out and
do your own romantic thing I mean it's
the 21st century girl you know I mean oh
well let me ask you do guys come up to
you and start talking to you
nah not a lot maybe I just don't come
off too friendly
but guys still approach you right in
your mind do you think like okay here
comes another creep I think it's more
the environment it depends on where I'm
at if I'm in a club and everyone's kind
of drunk I'm just like I don't really if
it was like gonna you know a more
supermarket a supermarket or library at
a ballpark doing random interview you
know what I mean itself like that yeah
what do your hands say about you my
hands yeah currently I have a gorgeous
engagement ring Oh congratulations thank
you
he's the most incredible man ever I also
you can tell about me that I don't know
what you would call it brave or
something maybe I have some little hand
tattoos one of them it's a quote on the
side of my hand it says still I rise and
I ended up getting it because I've
always loved the poem from Maya Angelou
but in symbolism with it is that I'm a
diabetic and I've almost died like
several times for my sugars being too
low and so anytime I got to that I was
able to rise so still I rise my blood
sugars and just out of that that state
you know
leave you something I wrote a while back
now that I'm thinking about it it's you
can think of hands in a different way
you know it's not just our physicalities
it's you can look at my hands and know
that I have touched people who I love
you know I have touched things that I've
loved my hands have wrapped themselves
around me in the most needed times no
the list goes on
do you have any like modifications or
you know not too many I don't have any
tattoos I have my ears pierced just the
regular way that's it really what's the
most painful thing you've been told I
don't know when I was young my you know
dad can be like my father just he got
angry and I did something wrong and he
said I'm not gonna amount to anything
you're worthless and all that if I fail
it just seems like I'm not gonna amount
to anything good you know what I mean
I'm a failure so the thought is still
there sadly but once again being
positive kind of helps I guess but the
idea of what he said still kind of
haunts me it's hard the most people
think someone's told me I think is that
they don't love me back
I think that that's one of the most
painful things someone can never tell
you yeah especially when you love them
very much I talk about family members or
someone in my case assisted a
significant other okay I asked oh and
they were like beating around the bush
no they said no they said no and I asked
a couple more times because I didn't
believe that and again it was a no yeah
like how long you been going out to like
together at the point I was with them
for two years
okay ELISA was in three years you know
what I mean well it extended for six
years after that on and off yeah because
I still didn't accept the fact that they
said no when I asked if they loved me
and you should believe when someone
tells you that they don't love you
absolutely you must really care for this
person I did and I still kind of do it
just
takes time because I know how it feels
like the love still there and it's the
love for my ex is still there I think
will always be there I think what are
you gonna do we gotta move on right how
else we're gonna move on with life you
just gotta do what we got to do you know
like we got it we have to yeah we just
have to yeah do you believe in God
yes have you ever questioned God I do
believe in God I've had a lot of
experiences that have made me feel like
I know that God is there and I know that
he's real and I can wrestle with doubt
but at the end of the day to invalidate
those experiences is to invalidate like
the foundation of my life so I've heard
that non-believers still go through a
near-death experience and then all of a
sudden they're like holy crap I was
praying to God in that moment you know
is that how you started to believe or
were you brought up to believe it it's
always been something like a force in my
life and I've always felt connected to
it and I've had more and more
experiences over the years like
something that you're talking about I
had a pretty bad ski accident where I
fell down the mountain like really fast
and probably ultimately should have
broken a lot of bones or died I'm
tumbling probably 50 or 60 miles an hour
down this mountain uncontrollable and I
yelled out loud please God stop or
please God and the minute I did that I
was currently heading towards one of
those big polls and I was probably gonna
shatter my body and basically in that
moment I stopped in the snow right
before that pole and
I mean some people can say oh it's
coincidence oh it was this or that and
for me that's where I land is that God
protected me
okay what about you I believe God is art
and within us it's within other people
it's not this white male with long hair
you know I don't really believe in Jesus
and I never did
I grew up Christian but eventually my
family stopped going do you believe in
God if yes have you ever questioned God
I don't know if I necessarily believe in
the biblical God I do believe in a
higher power
I don't know what it is or where it is
but I know there's I believe there's
something bigger out there for us yeah I
get it
what about you I do I was grow up
Catholic you know what I mean
I mean I have my own rules I know if
you're nice to people then I think
you're doing all right you know what I
mean so I guess that's what my faith is
just as long as I'm nice to people you
know I'm thankful for what I have
you know I just have faith you just try
to find some sort of miracle in everyday
you know all right so what do you think
I look like yes I mean you told me that
you were God in middle school I have a
feeling you still like the color black I
think that you I think you have darker
hair
we know you have tattoos and I think you
have like hazel eyes and Natalie
you have a powerful voice and that
speaks a lot about a person's character
you have a lot of strength I feel like
you're one of those people that actually
does show up and is reliable looks don't
matter but you're beautiful
thank you like seriously thanks for
existing I think you're a really nice
kind person I guess the world really
needs that around here
easy to talk to easy to befriend you
know honestly I cannot wait to turn
around and see who you are thank you be
bad number
okay I'm not very great at compliment so
I'm going to try my best I just make
stuff up I guess no I want to be honest
I think you're very easy to talk to I
don't think we had a lot of awkward
pauses which is kind of rare at least
for me
you seem really relaxed as well you
don't seem very tense and angry which is
also rare to find them it's not every
day you get to meet random people and
they actually have a conversation this
way we're made to talk you know to me
like we have to talk maybe that's the
way or just walk back to back while
talking to people it would be one thing
are you Brazilian I am Brazilian oh how
do you know your Brazilian friends are
you doing I heard you think about Brazil
and are you latina I am I am I'm Mexican
American okay got it right but I never
felt home in Brazil then I moved to
Boston I never felt home there then I'm
here and I don't feel I mean now my
niece is born I guess I have a reason
you know yeah I don't something actually
I guess everyone all right good job
everybody
all right let's do this
hi okay how you like we love it yeah
yeah I look like what you got no not at
all not at all amazing beautiful fiance
yet I don't know where he was eventually
I saw him walk off yeah I want to know
the big reveal now one two three
hi hi how are you good how are you not
too bad not too bad hang in there okay
do you want my phone number just in case
to talk about it okay everyone
throughout here I wanted to say thank
you for watching this episode I am still
selling these sweaters on my website if
you're interested I'll link in my
description I love you guys and I'll see
you next week
[Music]